[Música]
essa vai ser a jogada mais política que
você já viu meu nego esse casco aqui tem
história viu história do tamanho desse
ceará o melhor
esse brasil não deixam não falta deste
fantástico quando ele schipper fogo aí
sim você pode tocar e postar subir
viajar e fazer o que você quiser mas por
enquanto não
ai aqui tem história viu muita história
de história vou a história de batalha de
vitória de sonhos
muitos o sonho sim igual aos que você
tem um sonho de amor de libertação de
coragem de a deixa pra lá vai mas e aí
você está empolgada e terminar de
construir sua própria data junto onde
vou revogar boston em hora de chegar o
teu gosto dessa jogada eu vou ensaiar
mundo vai falhar senão não processados
kurata eu tenho que ser julgado ele
falhar também pra ir pra capital eu vou
encontrar cecília ea gente vai ficar
junto passeata ó eu e ela voltou só
nosso viu a ela vai cantar eu você
palhaço e depois de tudo isso ainda
vamos viajar de jogada por todas se
mudam
só que a gente tem que terminar de
construir essa tua jogada nessa envolveu
sucessivos e permite o ceptro na emissão
mais que conseguir ficou o ovo agradece
então pra começar e pedale aquela caixa
de ferramentas
ai ai
[Música]
a droga
o pardal abaixadinha aqui né
agora me passa iap luta bio bachin a
piu-piu ó órgão vai dar vai dar o que
vôou ao vai dar pra terminar de
construir a jogada
cuba é a maneira que a gente constrói a
jogada é o meu deus 2 que sim
completamente que não tinha mais o bahia
o eco esqueci isso não é bom eu vou
fazer o seguinte eu vou lá fora procurar
piúva e você fica aqui na não deixem
nada tá bom na onde fique só pastorando
apache opel bola' ó
[Risadas]
[Música]
o mérito de todo o vencedor é a
curiosidade não sei
francisco mas pode me chamar de chip
chico da matilde
então você o menino que quer ganhar o
mundo você olha eu já me falar de você
viu não sei que gondomar
quem sou eu mesmo vou voltar a falar de
você mas é claro o vôo chega aqui vou eu
to aqui cavar o vôo do dragão do mar
carro ele não pode o viajante não foi
você que viajou uma jogada nessa jogada
essa só vou saber das coisas jogar dia
está sendo feita com o que sobrou do
casco da minha jogada da sua sede tachou
a guardou por muito tempo
este era o casco da minha jangada
só porque eu fui até o rio de janeiro a
capital do país sozinho nesta jogada por
amor
igualzinho a você eu amo muito vocês
ilha e seus pais você ama amo e seu avô
seamus ruim ama sua terra mas só gente
eu amo muito traz o dragão quer que você
precisa mais
na verdade agora
agora eu preciso de pio até mais
complicado ficar aí
[Música]
eu posso contar um segredo olha que
segredos foram feitos para serem
guardados não seria um segredo e eu vou
fugir com o circo amanhã eu quero fugir
com o circo é só para ser palhaço não
mas é que a cecília vai ser minha
namorada e é claro que vou casar com ela
agora um obstáculo que está causando o
impedimento nesse planejamento tarde
vida é que amanhã ela vai pra capital
sobre o pai dela não tem dinheiro e amor
amor amor e se eu acho que ele sente
muito por ela quem é o pai da sicília
está fazendo tudo que pode ele está
dando o seu melhor ele ama sua família
eu sei
amor em sonho de uma vida melhor
eu também fui da capital por amor por
conta da desigualdade nesse rodadas o
dragão boa aqui no brasil tinha uma
coisa chamada escravidão as pessoas que
eram negras ação eram tratados como
gente elas não tinham vida aí eu fui eu
fui até a capital do país pedir para que
essas pessoas fossem libertadas
muita gente duvidou que fosse chegar até
ela
mas eu cheguei
e foi tão bonito fim à escravidão
[Música]
pena que até hoje há resquícios disso
tudo nosso
mas o que eu quero te falar vim aqui o
ceará será no assim ele tem alma livre
nós somos a abolição
[Música]
mas o que é que você precisa mesmo é e
piúva né mas eu também quero fazer muito
mais na sua história pode mudar com o
vitor onde leva pra viajar comigo não
sei se lá você vai encontrar pio mas
você vai conhecer mais um pouco da minha
história e da história do nosso ceará
[Música]
é
[Aplausos]
[Música]
[Risadas]
ora já chegou
eu posso à vista
o navegador
o dragão do mar
tá bom
romeu gonçalves
pet viagem
[Aplausos]
o gesto já nada
[Música]
chita da rádio
mateus rocha
ora já chegou
bobby charlton
a dona
ah
o troco
roma
dia de festa
foi fechado
a cabeça
[Música]
o da partilha
ora taxa
só sabe fechar
ora o dragão do mar
o gol do maicon salva
tá de pé
a empresa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o jeito da rádio
olha já chegou
[Música]
é essa a razão que adaptar máquinas de
café quando léa leva quatro horas para a
minha terra banana apostou na carreira
de chapa petista a bola vai rolar às
balas eu também vou bater o botafogo
olha lá
[Música]
bom
é vamos desejar é dia de festa
[Aplausos]
o ego do salvar chegou da batida
é hora de festejar
é dia de festa no maracanã
é é o salto
o tipo da batida
o tetracampeão
é vamos festejar é dia de festa julina
é como eu vou salvar o tipo da martins
ah
[Música]
ei vamos festejar é dia de festa de
iemanjá
é como é bom salto chico da matilde
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se achou o musical
assista na íntegra
de quinta a domingo às 21 30 no teatro
ceará joe sempre às 20 30 horas na
avenida abolição 2323 no meireles
muito obrigado e aguardamos todos